voir recevoir un auteur compositeur qui
fait les gens sont si bas depuis si
longtemps
ce que c'est insidieux de plus quand on
se retrouvera en 1999 clôture à 20 ans
de métier match aller 6 pieds sous terre
d'accord bon mais il ya une différence
entre nous c'est que vous avez écrit
rajouter un point commun il ya un point
commun la différence et moi j'ai jamais
fait elles font ce gamin sauver
j'étais un marginal et p je vois ici
copyright 1964 du pays donnant 60 kw à 5
4 35 euros vision petit à petit la gt et
les portes se sont ouvertes et tu n'es
plus original c'est plus un marginal
mais c'est truqué c'est comment dire
quoi
c'est avec n'écoute pas les images
j'écoutais déjà beaucoup les jeux donner
le plus en plus je les couplets ah oui
j'ai choisi le meilleur
j'ai peur et je te résiste tuer c'est
pourquoi je sais bien ce que je vis seul
avec toi ou temps j'irais chez toi
puisque c'est comme ça
donc à cette épice que tu ne bois plus
écoutés
moi je suis fort
de toi bien entendu dans la bouche à
bouche
oui moi c'était plus romantiques la
rencontre que j'ai eue et france parce
que je lui ai écrit un texte que j'avais
envie qu'elles qu'elles disent qu'il ya
tellement cru finalement s'appeler la
déclaration
différents seuils ta vie privée aussi
quand je suis c'est que je peux rêver
joseph que je suis dans tes bras
le reste je te fait pas
une éclaircie
déclaration qu en justice elle que je
peux
t
que tu es là tout près de moi
imaginez
oui
une déclaration
déclaration
juste deux ou trois mots d'amour
pour te parler de nous
deux ou trois mots de tous les jours
c'est tout
quand je suis seul et que je peux
je rêve que je suis un thé bram qui
arrivent à la retraite
je rêve que tu me fait baver ce cliché
cette fin une déclaration latin des
crachats
ma déclaration
c'est joli c'est je le dis maintenant ça
c'est le la de l'art qui ici mais moi
j'ai les babys peuvent soixantaine de
photos dégénéré quand elle avait 14 ans
8 insolite un une relique taille l art
dans le détail a dit
à ça j'ai une vie peut ignorer les
dangers que représentent les libertés
il va d'être les menaces de guerre eux
semblent se préciser
ça va changer à cet instant baby tu ne
sais où tous les soleils mans se lever
quelque part sur la tête
bref il est des filets pas le siffler
le sang versé chante dans ce cas de prix
les pubs
déjà les mérites tarder
je veux
chan dans ce pays
comme si de ma bulle
petit patelin
tu
m et puis si mu va lancer mais c'était
un vrai test donc tu lui as pas écrit
des chansons que je chante toujours et
je peux être assassiné pas société de
consommation oui un peu elle a balancé
que chacun se mette à chanter quand tu
arrives en dit que chacun se laisse
emporter et chacun contre l'eau tous et
les succès ça suit ce marché contre
l'autre en lacets
c'est par votre fille qu'on fume un
partant vite hélas
on est trop faible pour s'entretuer
on est trop seul pour se les tests
pour la suite on est trop mal pour cent
ajouté
ne trouve rien pour se déchirer
les uns les autres musiques
des causes en nous
jaloux qui pourrait doucher elle nos
armées c'était donc lié à condé doit et
va trop loin
c'est efficace gentil ou méchant et
sucettes ça va plus loin
alors d'abord c'est une chanson que
douteux
pour franz absolue membres malades
absolument rien contre et 8 paniers mais
les sucettes
c'est un art et lee
6 7 1
me donner
tassé baiser
annie c'est lorsque le sucre
je ne
cm
ogeu dany
est ou pas
un des labels le pont génial mockel que
penny
parmi eux à csu cette année
pas vraiment sans la couleur de ses
grands yeux la couleur des choses
heureux à la ce point rien compris à ce
texte et ce gala via quelqu'un ces
derniers temps pourquoi qui lui
demandait pourquoi changer pas cet
indice est mon âge
enfin si la chanson géniale qu'il a fait
le plus de mal videmment parce qu'on
fait un don en ville de l'utah c'est
simple et c'est romantique
la lune en secret bien
je t'en mets
les nuages triste vont s'amuser sans
corde et rim en indien vient
je t'emmène
le sol est le soir se reposer j'ai
tellement fermé les yeux
j'ai tellement rêver
j'y suis arrivé
bien
justin mai
roy l'autre côté
ja
u 20
j'ai tellement fermé
j'ai tellement ri
2 j lui arrive
alors ouvrir à ses yeux la réalité les
rimes en un mois je vais te donner une
leçon de prosodie
moi je prenais toujours l'événement axes
x il à dire
c'est beaucoup plus difficile si j'ai
pas d'idée j'ai pas les mêmes le
motoriste des souks un peu texte je ne
veux
avoir des réflexes ma
dans
il faut que tu restes ce qui est qu'un
demi
en te dire adieu
sous aucun prétexte je ne
van toi / exposer mes yeux
un clinic ce show est mieux te dire
adieu
je mise à l'index
une blanche
françois sans plus
- x
déduplication vaudrait mieux
mais bof
j'arrive pas critiquer je me sens pas
non mais françois c c'est la star qui
veut pas être star et c'est vraiment une
interprète fantastique
alors moi j'ai bêtement suivi j'ai aussi
fait une chanson pour françoise jeu
c'est sa quatrième bougie très juteux
des semaines
rejet
jusqu'à perdre haleine bien
v et
si tu crois jeu
et si ce jour
de ces chemins de mai
il y a
retrouvez
si tu crois jeu
le
aussi
obama
un problème
vous jusqu'à père
il y a
la passion j'ai suffisament très
malheureuse
lorsque nous vaut mieux dans la ville où
mieux attaquer ouais enfin de être
cynique c'est ça que peut devenir
cinoque mais aussi parce que tu es
quelqu'un de très froid non c'est pas ça
y'a un philosophe allemand s'est pas de
championnat qui à dix les animaux à 100
francs du venin bon alors un précepteur
ses cesmo un passage plus qu'à écouter
serge lui même parce que les auteurs
compositeurs fond si leurs chansons et
les chante
alors après le grand succès de sex and
sun il va nous chanter sous que ça va ça
lui va très bien
mr iceberg